peace be with you
welcome to the Dean show me to your host
we're going on fight not yet
we're almost there in 2016 we should hit
500 episodes that's right and we've been
going strong thank God and we're gonna
continue in Shalala we have our next
guest coming in the legendary Gracie
family I've had others on the show host
Gracie hunter Gracie
we got Horry and Gracie from the
legendary family who started the
Ultimate Fighting Championships we're
gonna be talking about you know Ramadan
is coming up and we want to make sure we
look obesity is on the rise diabetes
heart disease all of these things that
are slowly the food that we're eating is
slowly killing us yes
so Horine has taken off with this
wonderful eating regimen we're going to
be learning about it the Gracie diet so
we can get some tips for Ramadan how to
start it from his advice and how to end
with it what to put in our bodies so we
can be better prepared we gotta have it
bless it fast we will see when we come
back with our next guest here on today's
show don't go anywhere
this is the and welcome back to the D
show and with us all the way from
California Horry and Gracie how are you
sir thank you
now before we get into this very
important topic just we've had some of
the Gracie's on the on the Dean show
before Horry and Gracie tell us a little
bit about yourself have you heard of
this big event now because we know your
your family is into the martial I
trained the gracie brazilian jiu jitsu
most effective martial art in the world
by far now there's this up-and-coming
it's a huge big event is called the
Ultimate Fighting Championships have you
ever heard of it oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
you started it
is that right that's right when I came
to this space first time in 1969 I had a
very unique experience here my ticket
was stolen was gonna be a trip for about
a month and to be at it for one year he
gave me did a passion for the United
States I mean some good friends and then
I went back to Brazil in 1978 after I
finished law school I decided to come
back to the states with the objective of
establishing jujube so he's sharing with
the rest of the world it was my dream
then so I put some nets in my garage
every first time bad anywhere I invited
for a free class and a guy loved it of
course and she came back and brought a
friend or give him another free class if
you brought ten friends I'll give him
ten free classes and that's how the word
start spreading around it was not
uncommon that sometimes a student would
say oh you're my former kungfu
instructor or karate or Thai boxing or
whatever does not believe in truth it
was to challenge you to a fight would
you accept that I said of course so he
will bring their former karate
instructors on different martial arts to
challenge here in the garage and of
course I'll tell my students you know
ah [ __ ] you know there's a challenge
match against this and that guy and they
sue the who follow up it love to watch
that kind of stuff and repeatedly
because YouTube is indeed the most
effective form of martial art you will
allow me to control my opponents without
having to bloody up anybody or hurt
anyone in a very loving way hug those
guys put him on the ground squeeze their
necks a little bit play around a little
bit
and ultimately they will give up and say
wow this stuff is amazing when I learned
this so the large majority of people
that came to challenge me eventually
became friends and students and that's
how the West was won over and over
hundreds of times I had those
challenging backs in my garage doing a
pillow over 10 years when I was teaching
on my garage and eventually it dawned on
me that if I came to the United States
would you objective over sharing the
audiovisual juicer developed by my
family with the rest of the world I
could not be a little tiny garage in
Hermosa Beach I have to say Bay and
that's when I came up with the concept
of creating your tournament which is
your Fighting Championship to compare
different styles of martial arts against
one another
I put hoist in their little tiny little
voice goes in there does the job shows
everybody the effectiveness of Gracie's
resume so and the rest is history you
know and I know you're here yeah we had
a hoist so your brother not too long ago
on the program tell us we see in this
clip now is this a cont fuel guy it
seems like you're giving him one of
these Gracie hugs he's rushing at you
this seems like this is from the Gracie
in action and now you're stepping back
then you step in you give him a hug
what's going on here what you see there
you know you want to avoid the business
where they can't be dangerous with this
right and as soon as there's an
opportunity you close the gap take him
to the ground and ultimately for
submission so that's the plan every
single time it works like charm now
let's talk about something I mean so
detrimental I mean this is something
that I'm just blown away I'm
flabbergasted the more I look into this
it's like a whole orient a whole new
world is open up to me I can see now
that I've changed my diet I'm eating
different I've eliminated certain things
from my diet you know it's just amazing
I want to really share this with
these basic things that people can do
that can really dramatically change
their life we see diabetes heart disease
you know cancer all these things that
were you know basically unknown at a
certain time now it's an epidemic
obesity and you you're somebody who's
also you've taken on this challenge and
you're also educating like you where
people on the most effective martial art
now you're educating people on diets
well it's not exactly a diet first of
all I think people don't understand the
real secret of the that's the trick and
it shouldn't be called a diet any
because you're not restricted from
eating basically anything you want the
trick is how to combine the foods within
a certain meal and cocon was my father's
older brother you seen 65 years of his
life say food combining he was not a
doctor was a self-taught nutritionist
but he's read the words of scientists
and doctors and experts in all kinds of
areas of healthy nutrition to finally
come up with his own conclusions of what
should be mixed within a meal in order
to avoid acidity of your system because
the city is what causes all kinds of
health problems so if you can't have a
meal in which the the ingredient for the
items of that deal we combined together
with mix together with that same process
of digestive process they bring about
alkalinity in your body instead of
acidity then you're doing great but it's
my accident or by habit or because you
don't know about it my ignorance you mix
certain ingredients of that food that
are not combining properly those
ingredients might cause a silicon your
system and therefore you can have your
heartburn your headache you carry your
stomach aches and gastritis and all
kinds of health issues that we are just
not aware you know eating is something
almost very much almost control your
great-grandmother taught your
grandmother your grandmother plus your
mom your mom teaches you and you're
probably gonna teach your kids things
you can eat things that you enjoy eating
in my family instead of eating just eat
something because it tastes good we have
all been taught to be something because
it's good for you good for your health
so ultimately that's the trick we have
to learn to like what's move for you
the person who likes cigarettes or life
sweet or crack cocaine the fact that he
likes it doesn't make good for him so
the trick is to learn to choose if these
are good for you already beneficial for
your health let's PT have you heard this
statement let food be your medicine and
medicine be your food what do you think
about this what do you think about the
statement that's what the whole idea is
about people usually eat inlet guide it
by the flavor of my D tastes of certain
foods
that's what determined what they eat the
trick is like I said learn to like
what's good for you that's the magic you
don't want to grasp that concept and
change your perception or your real
looking at food it's something that must
be beneficial for your health
you saw something just with your face
and come up your belly now someone says
ok I agree with that [ __ ] Ian mr.
Gracey I like to supersize it okay I
like a lot of sugar I like you know
brownies and Twinkies and supersize it
sometimes I'll give it a take different
tastes I go to Burger King right I mean
what are your thoughts on this well you
tried a cantaloupe juice squeeze you
know fresh-squeezed orange juice with
four or five bananas in a couple of acai
yeah guys you don't know their stuff you
don't know what you're missing so if you
want to have the brownies and the sugar
and the fat and the coffee and all that
kind of stuff because it tastes good you
are not taking in consideration another
aspect of your of your life that could
eventually pay big benefits by eating a
just stuff your face itself it tastes
good but not very good quality stuff
might be for your health
eventually you will it be a price for
them you know and then it's just a
pressure of choice life is about choices
I'm pushed out suggest them to get a
bowl of the book degrees to die for look
at some of the recipes
and suggestions of music in there
probably a lot of subjects already thing
already like you just not mix it in
right that's the key
we're gonna take a break you heard that
with the Gracie diet we're gonna be
talking about more of that here in the
disha Ramadan is right around the corner
we're gonna get some advice on how you
can start your day eating right because
long days fasting here with Horry and
Gracie when we come back don't go
anywhere
right back
this Ramadan brings with it 18-hour
fasts and the peak of summer a challenge
for the body and mind in this short
video we look at what happens to your
body when you fast less blood will be
flowing to your digestive system when
you fast so more blood will be sent to
other tissues in your body in addition
your body will use the fasting period to
remove deposits of cholesterol that line
the blood vessels when you breathe your
body can absorb thousands of toxins
which is used in the environment around
us fasting helps us remove the toxins
that have built up within your lungs
your stomach uses a time during fasting
to clean itself and remove any wastes
later so now for more efficient
digestion your intestines also use the
time during fasting to clean themselves
and remove any wastes later turn now for
more efficient digestion your liver
provides the body with glycogen the
secondary energy source and breaks down
fat to provide glycerol another energy
streams when you are fasting your
kidneys increase the amount of diuresis
the process of excretion of salt and
water which leads to lower blood
pressure the month of fasting can be
extremely beneficial for us mentally
spiritually and physically as long as
you eat the right foods and don't push
yourself too hard physically you may
find yourself in a healthier state at
the end of the month
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with Horry and Gracie
from the legendary Gracie family by far
there's no doubt about it again going
back and we'll come back to going there
isn't it's it's proven most effective
martial art in the world is that without
a doubt by now there's the martial arts
on the ground you're gonna get into a
quaint just a few punches and kicks and
if you don't have the knowledge of the
ground game you have no chance so my
dream of sharing results with the world
was absolutely accomplished since the
creation do you see now the word is
getting around the army the Armed Forces
are using it every branch is here
embracing this concept in every major
federal law enforcement agencies now
more and more utilizing the techniques
of yeah so this is a family that has a
very good track record this is proven by
science leverage this is now something
you said the key to that we're talking
about the food now this is another
aspect that is rarely touched upon most
people are uninformed in this area and I
think now hopefully we can reach out a
whole new audience and people I have
found just by eliminating certain thing
I personally I mean people don't have to
do this but I read a fabulous article
and one of the leading heart surgeons he
talked about one of the leading causes
for heart disease heart disease with
sugar so I call sugar poison be the real
problem is the food companies who load
their products up with sugar which
critics call dangerous and addictive
sugar is poison diabetes heart disease
lipid problems strokes cancer those
diseases are being driven by sugars in
my home I've replaced it with other
substitute raw honey
with stevia talked about could we talk
about sugar a little bit refined sugar
is what people like sweet I love if you
put in front of me I'm in but more
importantly how do you eat that sugar
I have meals for example if I have a
fish or some risotto or some vegetables
I'm not gonna eat that with a sweet
dessert even though people are
accustomed of having a little dessert
because it tastes good you satisfy their
sweet tooth sugar we combine its fat
which is the ingredients that is used to
prepare your face or your rice or your
vegetables whatever it is sugar fat
that's the real that's the bomb that's
the problem to have sugar alone or mixed
with the right things it's bad for you
especially because we find sugar but
it's not as damaging as if you mix sugar
with fat that we have it for dessert so
if I'm happy like I said fish and some
rice and some vegetables as a meal for
lunch for example I'm not gonna have
dessert on that meal but I would have a
sweet meal later on in the day last
night for example a watermelon juice I
had some rye crackers
I had a slice of cheese it had some
dates so that's the way from you to
satisfy my future's in a meal that does
not conflict with the previous immune
because it's four and a half hours of
partridge to learn the basic concept and
then you can have your sweet satisfy
your sweet tooth in a way that's very
healthy in any case you're going forever
with good health and all there the
energy so we can do we can take out this
what you said refined sugar and replace
it with the natural sugars you mentioned
one thing is omit the date dates are a
great substitute is that right honey you
know eat sweet things and then combine
it properly and it's a clip right now
that they're seeing of a journalist
showing the coca-cola present
and how many packs of sugar are actually
in and this is one thing I want you to
take off with just eliminating and this
is also another acidic food falls on
there acidic is the pops right the sodas
if we eliminate now this from our from
our from our fridge sugar in each hole I
mean so the question I have this to the
parents are there and what age you see
people use for great to clean you know
the stains to clean yes your baby when
he's a year old or six months old or two
years old and what age it's okay we know
College poison everybody knows that but
it tastes like I said the last thing
they want is to worry about your health
they just want to sell another coat so
different parent knowing that coca-cola
is bad for your health seems the kid at
coca-cola I mean what the heck what is
he thinking you're gonna say it's known
that one glass your body works on that
Sidney level between 6.75
at 7.25 that's the range the body try to
maintain itself in terms of a city
personal community right here if you
drink a glass of soda it has a 2.5
sitting in it you need to drink 32
glasses on good water to wash off that
one glass of coca-cola you literally
have to drown yourself
32 glass of water no way does their so
normally that stuff is really bad for
your health
next time your kid is in the restaurant
and say dad I want a cold I'm telling
you now if you say hey kid waiter read
the little kid a coke
you actually help me the point that your
own child don't do that alienate your
sort of the demos the best thing you can
do right how do you recommend I saw a
very I mean this is like a documentary
I was excited about purchasing and
giving out to people it's called fed up
have you seen this documentary
all fed up it's been called dangerous
it's been called addictive and it's in
almost everything we eat sugar tonight
the food industry is up in arms over a
controversial new movie accusing big
food of peddling unhealthy sugar filled
products especially to our kids but if I
will approach this epidemic has been
dead wrong the new movie fed up yeah
this is and that's the thing really
getting educated tell us some of the
concepts now of the great of the Gracie
way of eating okay this is the basic
concept number one you should only have
three meals a day at least four and a
half hours apart so if you have
breakfast at 8 o clock in the morning
you should not eat anything we did four
and a half to five hours so you have to
allow your meal to be completely
digested before you need anything else
the idea of eating every three hours
like many nutritionists suggests it's
not good for your health they're all so
number one space there's at least four
and a half to five hours apart more than
that is okay but nevertheless important
half to five hours so that's number one
rule number two you have cooked food
somebody's prepared its fat or oil or
butter you should not have sweets with
it in other words after eating your
cooked meal do not eat dessert not
eating a fruit nothing like that you're
hungry asked for another state have
another pizza but do not eat fat or
sweets or shot me so I don't eat sugar
or sweets with as I desert for that meal
a glass of juice and nothing like that
okay in rule number three you should
have one starts per meal in other words
if you're having bread you should not
have french fries bread and potatoes at
different start you should not be mixing
the same meal so you can help bread
pasta pizza and crackers because they
all made a we is okay but don't have
potatoes and bread hammering fish frying
bad combination over there so those are
the three basic concepts there of course
may explain more a glance at the Gacy
diet book or the Gacy diet.com website
we can have much more information that
but those are appear to be concepts the
people happy game I have found I found
now you know that the Creator is put all
of this one
of food in the earth you know the fruits
and vegetables and I mean if we anything
that would you advise staying away from
anything that's gone through the human
process now and going more towards the
natural way we call it processed foods
that would be a wise thing to do any but
it's not realistic say you can't see
people don't eat anything that's
processed I mean you just can't do it
everywhere you go there's you don't have
access unless you give them a farm in
the middle of nowhere and you had a
little plant everything and raised
everything that would be ideal but this
is utopia we can't do that realistically
more importantly than the quality of
this food that you're eating in other
words you don't have to eat everything
organic only I don't do that I need some
things organic and some things are just
so not such great work any for that so I
eat the food even though it's not
organic like I said more important than
just happy Organic of everything is
combining the foods properly
that's the trip you can't have a
hamburger and you can't have french
fries
just don't eat the hamburger with the
french fries because the bread and the
potatoes are bad combination
now we all know that if you don't sell a
hamburger for a dominant for 99 cents
and they're literally making a killing
with that by making a lot of profit with
that you know the quality of the meat is
the worse the quality of the bread is
the worst we know all that so it's up to
you to become more informed if selected
but I want to have that meat but it's
very cheap very convenient but I Drive
by and it tastes good because got a lot
of fat and shredded although I want to
be a little more concerned about my own
health or my family's health it's I'd be
a little more selective of the process
so that's the trick you have to become
more aware of it and again changing your
current eating habits it's probably one
of the most difficult things there is
but it's worth looking into it and it's
an easy read the greasy diet books are
very easy be you've read it a couple of
days and you do so much information you
can take very gradual changes you can
take one step at a time make one little
change every day
wake up in the morning get a glass of
water Percy you don't wanna yeah well
maybe so substitute more more more water
instead of the pop and the sodas and the
shoe yeah of course
we're going to take a break and we right
back with more we want some advice from
you we're going to be starting Ramadan
this is the fifth pillar of Islam and we
need some advice for all those who are
fasting we're gonna get it from you is
that okay we're going right back here
with Horry and Gracie from the legendary
Gracie family her daddy's show don't go
anywhere
misconception Muslims are terrorists
this is by far the biggest misconception
of Islam given unfairly by stereotyping
in the public image that the media gives
has anyone else noticed how when a
specific group of people attack another
group of people it is labeled as a hate
crime but when a Muslim opens fire on
anybody it is quickly regarded as
terrorism many political dictators and
officials or extremist groups use the
name of Islam as a strategy to garner
followers and attention when many of
their practices go against the true
basis of Islam the media has also
portrayed Islam as a cult or a club
where if you join you become a terrorist
and that is now part of your agenda
however all over the world people
practice Islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life
there are many verses in the Quran that
go against the idea of terrorism some of
these verses include fight the way of
Allah those that fight you but do not
transgress limits for God does not love
transgressors this basically means do
not fight except in self-defense and
even in doing so do not go beyond
offense another verse states if they say
peace then you seek peace which means do
not attack people for no reason or kill
innocent people there is nowhere in
Islam whether it be in the Koran or the
teachings of Muhammad that promotes the
killing of innocent people
I want you to imagine you wake up and in
front of you are a bunch of guys running
around kicking a ball no goals no lines
no rules what would you think but is
that your life surely every sport has
its goal every game has its end it has
its objective it has its rules how about
life how about our life isn't there a
goal to life isn't there a purpose an
objective that we have to reach we think
so the Koran tells us that we exist in
order to worship God and worshiping God
means knowing God as the Quran says when
the holocrons in know will insert allure
Leah Badoon worship though is not some
narrow small thing its wide its vast it
encompasses everything that the human
being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal please subscribe to
the video follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here with whoring Gracie now many people
they think look you go supersize it and
it's it's pretty cheap it's it's pretty
affordable but you know people think wow
you know if I want to eat healthy it's
it seems very expensive what do you have
to say to this well first of all people
haven't they don't think equal adoration
a couple of things number one we need
fast food that kind of stuff you keep
had they had nearly throughout the whole
day so if you think about how much money
you spend on snacks and little tiny
things like that it does add up number
one number two in terms of eating
healthy if you're more selective on what
you're eating in my cost so a little bit
more
now but you're safe on doctor bills and
hospital bills for the long run trust me
just pay now or pay later
you know the fact that you might spend a
couple more bucks and select a food that
is healthier for you now you make it
through so much but it's so much better
so much more energetic so much more
ready to deal with everything then if
you eat just anything and stuff your
favorite stuff that you don't mean food
that you like but it's not good for you
before you know you have to spend money
on medicine you have to take your
outfits else's and your tums and your
entire assets and all that kind of stuff
you know doctor bills and everything
else it's not worth it spent two weeks
experience I mean expiry making with the
greasy diet and you're gonna feel so
much better never turn back I mean this
is it I am so excited and so sure about
this stuff that I wanna now see you
right here please go ahead get the JC
guidebook for greasy diet comb website
get the book
try the grace of that for two weeks if
you don't feel better
send me the book back that's I mean that
sounds like a great deal nobody gives
you them go to Barnes & Noble buy any
book you want read it and say I didn't
like it I want my money back because I
said get lost
but I'm so confident and so committed to
this cause of a healthy people's would
have a better life that I'm willing to
give you the money back if you try the
diet for two weeks
you don't feel amazing and I know that
you're gonna try it you're gonna feel
better and you're gonna say gosh this is
good my family do it Corian tell us now
we're coming across the time of the year
that we fast Muslims fast as long as
based on five pillars one is to to
acknowledge that the Creator created us
and to be thankful for all the wonderful
blessings and he alone do we worship and
Muhammad is the last final measure
that's the first pillar then we pray
five times a day give to the poor and
then we have Hajj once in a lifetime and
fasting everyone knows about Ramadan I'm
sure you've heard about it right so we
wanted wanted your advice as an expert
in this area we start off just to give
you some familiarity we start off before
the break of dawn
well we'll get up we can eat okay and
typically traditionally we'll have dates
water and whatever else so what would be
your advice when we get up to hydrate
ourselves because all day
we stay away from drinking eating
relations with the spoused wife and then
when the Sun Goes Down at the break at
the sunset then we can go ahead and many
people day instead of the end of
feasting now they end up just overdoing
it so that what would be your advice
starting too fast and then what to break
it with to get ready again we got to do
this for 30 days that's no doubt on that
so you have to have a good hearty meal
I've said before in the morning so that
you can hold you off the rest of the day
I recommend that you break the fast with
something lighter
with something with some fruits and in
something a little more light to break
the fast after go home because he allows
your body to hydrate better instead of
just starting your face with you know
meats and all that kind of stuff too
much I don't have that before the fast
you know that's my suggestion so that
you have enough fuel in your body for
late road longer throughout the day and
then break the faster some fruits and
meals and cheeses and stuff like that a
little more DJ's and stuff a little more
light it to break the fast that way if
Ramadan with no for sure has the
objective of cleansing the person's body
and spirit yes thank you is that in a
way fasting is not just a physical
fasting but fasting in all aspects of
your life and me really looking into it
appreciating and showing gratitude and
understanding and accept me the whole
leadership of the Creator whatever going
to say that way if that's rejected what
if instead of looking at your way of
eating only during Ramadan a person
would consider what they're eating in
other words be aware of it not just
during Ramadan but doing your whole life
you know why would you just pick out
they eat everything if it's not Ramadan
season stuff your face with everything
else he's fed up considering every meal
almost says I'm holy as a holy
experiences I wonder for Trudy I prepare
a meal at my house here for the kids for
us it's almost like a ceremony that
happens every single day so I will wait
for one specific day of the year or a
specific time of the year
really be careful what I eat was said
once a month I fast I don't need
anything for 24 hours just as a way not
only for me to help me cleanse my body
but a way for me to detach from the need
of eating something till I have to stuff
my face all the time by spending a day
of months without eating anything it
just reminds me because there's much
bigger things out there than just eating
eating is just a way of nourishing my
body not a way to stuff my face so if we
take seriously and look at the advice
and objective of the Ramadan and so we
can cleanse your body during that period
why not look at every single meal for
the rest of your life there's a way to
nourish your body is an intelligent way
in a positive and healthy way you know
so I think it for me much more profound
than that
do you them for a month is Britain is
important in a way to embrace the whole
world that followed the guideline can do
it that way but my step my suggestion is
look at every meal with respect and
appreciation for your body your body's
your temple we don't have the right to
mess it up by feeling it the junket and
Guam stuffing I don't care how I feel I
just want to stuff my fish don't do that
that is in a sense you're breaking the
laws of the Creator you know it gives
you the template your obligation it's
your responsibility to do the best you
can why don't you get sick why would you
accept the idea of eating a meal and
then feeling so bloated and sickened and
with a heartburn that you have to take a
medicine to a pencil piece of art or to
count that now if I take a medicine you
take your way or heartburn why don't you
eat something that does not give you the
heartburn this is a wonderful brilliant
advice this is also in our tradition
that we are not supposed to be stuck
what you're saying exactly but it's the
shame that you know it's one thing what
we're told to do and it's another thing
what people are doing before we conclude
we got a couple more minutes and see we
see in this diet wonderful thing you
stay away from alcohol oh so
pork also this is amazing it's very
similar to you know what we're supposed
to stay away from here yeah this is
amazing so closing comments and advice
what you want to say you mentioned I get
the book where can they get it and what
are out what we're outside you can tell
us from your years of experience I mean
you you
you got a lot of experience you've over
the years tell us my advice is this all
bad things happen for a good reason
so if anybody out there is really any
kind of health issues
don't take a medicine to solve that
problem the same way just rising up on
the freeway
and their little red light blinks on the
panel do put a band-aid over it fix it
so if your body ever if you feel a
hardcore headache any kind of medicine
for that instead of taking a medicine
which would be a band-aid looking for
what the way you're eating and fix it so
that your body can heal itself it's the
best planet present we can get from the
Creator is that healthy body so based on
get your book if you don't like it
or in I'd like to thank you again so
much for all the wonderful work you and
your family have been doing over the
years thank you god bless you thank you
so much all right thank you very much
and thank you very much hor en Gracie
for being with us here on the D show to
cover this very very important topic it
is so important like I said an open up I
mean the food that we're eating look it
could be a medicine for you that's right
you're putting the right foods in your
body
this blessed body the crater's given us
and we take care of it and take care of
us put the wrong things in the body
that's right you're going to be end up
going to the doctor who's just going to
prescribing medications that's just
going to get you hooked and probably
with 2030 different side effects and
that's it it's a down road roller
coaster and hopefully we can get get
this book that he had mentioned the
Gracie diet watch get informed eliminate
a lot of the junk foods processed foods
the foods now that are not good for your
body the sugar is replace it with some
of the substitutes we talked about raw
honey dates stevia eliminate the pops
coke this poison and drink more water
the fresh fruits and the vegetables that
the Creator has given us and really get
hydrated when you start the day with the
fast and we
and and look he had given some brilliant
wonderful advice that from the tradition
from the lies the fundamental problem
aha my peace be upon him who had said
the son of Adam feels nothing worse than
the belly was he not saying it look
overindulging in fool we need to make
this a way of life that's right then we
see the benefits making this way of
eating a way of life so not over
indulging and not feasting after the
fast and not just watching what we eat
during romina but your whole life and
then the hadith goes on enough for the
son of Animus to to fill his belly look
with a few morsels of food if he's
overtaken than one through one-third air
1/3 water one-third food this is from
the last final mission for Muhammad
peace be upon him I hope that you got
the bin I surely did was honored thank
you again hor en for being with us here
in the Dean show everybody tuning in all
the millions from all over the world who
catch us here on the different satellite
channels have a blessed Ramadan this
month and we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below